a remoção da vesícula biliar chamada
de colecistectomia
é normalmente realizada quando há
evidência de pedras com inflamação na
vesícula biliar
os sintomas da doença vesicular
normalmente constituído de dor interna
e tente na parte superior direita do
abdômen
sidão normalmente quando pedras
bloqueio temporariamente um dos dois
dutos que carregam a bílis da visícula
biliar para o intestino
se as pedras não passarem
a vesícula biliar pode inchar
informar que põe infeccionar
o que pode levar a sintomas mais severos
como na rússia os momentos
e febre
técnicas laparoscópicas mais recentes
requerem apenas em sessões minimamente
invasivas
eo período de recuperação é mais
curto
antes do procedimento uma linha
intravenosa ser administrada
e você pode receber um sedativo para
ajudá-lo a relaxar
a qualix cistectomia laparoscópica é
realizada sob anestesia geral o que o
faz dormir durante a operação
história natural dos músculos da
parede abdominal dando espaço para o
cirurgião ou trabalhar
você será entubado temporariamente
através de sua boca e garganta
para ajudá-lo a respirar durante a
operação
pode-se também inserir uma sonda
gástrica oral no estômago através de
sua boca para ajudar na drenagem de
fluidos ali produzidos
na maioria dos casos este procedimento
pode durar de 30 a 60 minutos
para se obter acesso à sua vizinha
coreia estruturas ao redor dela
o cirurgião
irá utilizar um instrumento agudo
chamado de foca para criar uma série de
pequenos buracos ou portas através da
parede abdominal
uma destas portas e geralmente
localizada num big up
eo tecido de carbono é então bombeada
através da porta um delicado para
bombear seu abdômen para cima de forma
visualizar melhor seu conteúdo
em seguida se o cirurgião irá inserir
o laparoscópio através da porto miley
cal
imagens de sua câmera são projetadas
em um monitores de vídeo na sala de
cirurgia utilizando-se de outros
instrumentos passados através de
várias postes
se o cirurgião irá alcançar a
vesícula biliar khost é a sua
principal artéria e duto
deposita lançar pode mostrar a gente e
mover através de uma das portas
antes de morrer o laparoscópio se o
cirurgião irá verificar possíveis
áreas de sangramento e outras tantas
quando laparoscopia removido uma
válvula de pôster deixarem posição
somente para permitir
que o dióxido de carbono saia do
abdômen
finalmente as incisões minimamente
invasiva serão suportadas ou grampeadas
e cobertas com ligaduras
após a cirurgia os tubos de
respiração e a sonda gástrica oral
serão removidos e você será
encaminhado para a área de
recuperação para monitoramento
você receberá na rússia indicou
conforme necessário
e que a progredir lentamente de uma
dieta líquida para uma dieta leve
então com uma dieta sólida
as vias intravenosa serão removidas
assim que seu sistema gastro-intestinal
se recuperar alguns pacientes de
colecistectomia podem receber alta do
hospital em até 24 horas pacientes com
recicle biliar infeccionada podem
necessitar de internação de mais um ou
dois dias